hey wassup guys my name is Hashanah and
welcome to another Love Dare tip today
we're gonna talk about software so what
software you should probably be using
for lot I'm Dan this is also especially
what I use okay there's obviously a lot
of software out there in the universe
so um you're free to use whatever you
like but these are the suggestions that
I have for you depending on your current
setup I guess and also on of course what
I use when I make games so first up we
have an idea okay an integrated
development environment this is this is
an application this is a program in
which you create software so it's a
program in which you write code okay so
the most obvious one probably if you've
been following my channel is eclipse
okay eclipse is up there the clips I
have to say is the best idea in the
world okay now they do have a version
for pretty much every language including
stuff like JavaScript they do have a C++
version of Eclipse of course it doesn't
come with the compiler so you have to
set that up yourself I have used it for
quite a bit I don't like it too much I
have to say but Eclipse for Java if
you're using anything else for Java
other than Eclipse then I don't know
what you're doing because eclipse is
eclipses where it's at
so again if you're developing in Java or
even in C++ I eclipses certainly up
there now there is Visual Studio okay my
I should've put a Microsoft out the
front there
so some Microsoft Visual Studio is also
free okay eclipse is free and open
source Visual Studio is an open source
but it is free at least the Express
Edition is there are professional
editions that cost money but they really
have features that you probably won't
need anyway so Visual Studio Express is
a free version of Microsoft Visual
Studio and that works with C++ C sharp
and a lot of other languages such as
Visual Basic and F sharp and all those
other crazy ones that I've never used
and then that probably haven't even seen
the syntax of but yes so if you use if
you're using C++ or C sharp my
recommendation would be to use Visual
Studio 2012 or higher so 2012 or 2013
not a big fan up 2010 I have to say I
don't like the interface and and a few
of the things that that I liked just
aren't there but 2012 and today
and thirteen other visual studio are the
visual studios to be using if you're
developing in C++ or C sharp okay if you
are developing in Java user Clips and if
you're using ActionScript of
ActionScript you just use flash okay
that's what's for sublime text if you're
cool okay put this there because um if
you're a cool cat and you like to be
like all Indian stuff you can use
sublime text okay I personally like I
really enjoy using sublime text for C++
even if I'm developing with libraries or
whatever and the reason is sublime text
is just such an awesome application that
um that it's just just amazing okay if
anyone here likes notepad plus plus
please don't subscribe for my channel
because I hate you know but uh I have to
say sublime text is probably the best
texts that are available in the universe
okay and I do like it a lot more than
notepad plus plus but um a sublime text
is beautiful if you if you're developing
in say plus plus you've got to
integrated build tools you can build
your own build you can build your own
build tools make files whatever again if
you're advanced if you're not then what
and I probably shouldn't be developing
in say plus boss for game and love them
there but sublime Texas is a viable
option for development in C++ but know
this it will be slower than Visual
Studio okay
it will take you longer than make a game
in sublime text in Visual Studio you
probably have more fun with it you'll
probably have less frustration with it
maybe as long as you get you make file
and build system feed out but some
Visual Studio of course guys like we're
talking about we're talking about
freaking 48 hours to make a game like
use it use an IDE sublime text is an IDE
isn't an ID by the way I'm not in love
yet but again you could use a blind test
with Java as well but you know why
eclipse is beautiful okay moving on 2d
graphics so if you're designing 2d
graphics whether that be menu images
backgrounds whatever anything that's 2d
anything was not already modeled
basically then you have a paint.net you
can get that a get painted on that okay
that's the website get paint on that
that is a free little image editor it
does everything very very well except
one thing text it sucks with text do not
use it for text
for text I would use something like
Adobe Photoshop okay now um Photoshop
versus paint.net if I'm doing pixel
editing so in other words I'm using the
pencil tool and I'm always just editing
pixels in like an na by its size texture
or 16 by 16 whatever kind of kind of
retro or old-school graphics paint.net
is the clear superior kind of thinking
okay Photoshop is way too heavy weight
pad on that is a nice lightweight
application that will help you design
and I guess develop really nice textures
and characters and all that stuff but
basically paint on that is a really good
personal letter if you're moving up in
the world to high resolution graphics
Adobe Photoshop is gonna be for you does
cost money it's about twelve hundred
dollars but you know I guess you get we
pay for it's really quite good
I personally am not as comfortable with
Photoshop as I'd like to be a believes
me on to my next point
Adobe After Effects okay sorry those of
you who know what Adobe After Effects is
it is a it's a it's a video compositing
tool right so in other words it's
responsible for bringing together layers
of video more layers of layers of pixels
and compositing them together
alright hence the name compositing now
I've used another reason I even put
After Effects here is that I've been
using After Effects for the better
portion of probably seven years now and
the reason is I used to use it
extensively for work I used to actually
for those of you don't know I did it
used to make some some television
advertisements for feed companies and
I've done a lot of freelance video work
and that was really where I was at
before I decided that I really wanted to
dive into game development and then I
started like teaching myself Java and
all that so that's the history of the
channel right there but um when I was
making these these videos and these ads
obviously they haven't they had a lot of
video in them so After Effects was like
my best tool honestly and last love them
they're actually I used it for under 27
I think I used it for um mmm I used it
for making my character well not really
but kind of making my character and
making all my textures and the game
looks really good okay because I'll for
effects has a lot of tools now
everything that you can do an offer
effects
you can probably do in Photoshop okay I
I think Photoshop has the advanced 3d
kind of layers and 3d perspective and
stuff that After Effects does have but
again I'm just not comfortable with
Photoshop I just don't know how to use
it okay I've used Photoshop probably all
up I don't know if I've used it for a
few years but I've probably used it like
for a collective amount of 20 hours and
so I've probably got hundreds and
hundreds of hours on After Effects maybe
even a thousand so on After Effects is
just my go-to okay it's if I want to get
something done and it needs to look nice
after effects where I go for big 2d
graphics or whatever okay so after
effects is definitely viable I've used
it I did use it last autumn day you guys
ever see me livestream it it's it's
phenomenal okay it's really good it
works as well for images as it does for
video okay that's pretty much it for 2d
graphics 3d graphics okay we're moving
up to the up to the big boy stuff now
order that's 3d studio max okay I've
used this as much as After Effects okay
because if my client wants a jet flying
through the scene and well 3d max is
where it's at so um Autodesk 3ds max is
phenomenal again it's my favorite 3d
modeling application out there it's the
one I've used the most and pretty much
the only one I've used because I I've
tried to use other ones I can't because
3d message is so good so um I think it's
up to like 2014 or something now I
haven't used any version pass 2012 but
it is a great great great 3d modeling
application and then again like it's
using self excessively in video in the
video game industry which was the number
one modeling application out there I
know that Assassin's Creed was made
actually everything was modeled and put
together and in 3d to do math as well so
you have that going for it now I'm
already asked also make another one
called my I haven't put it on here
that's better for things like animation
and film work and the reason again
there's better film work is because of
animation but you like honestly for game
development 3d 2d max where it's at you
also have other alternatives okay after
first I put there again because After
Effects is a lot of 3d capabilities as
well a lot of people don't realize that
is out there but the the problem with
alpha effects as well and the Rada puts
here but their problem with with all the
difference between those two is it you
know three she a massive Lashley output
a lot of times a 3d model okay that's
what you want for games alright it's
actually 3d data after effects will
always output 2d data
okay well opt out upload
output like a video or an image but if
you're making something that needs to
look 3d obviously everything on the
screen is 2d anyway when you when it
gets rendered by your graphics card
everything's 2d if you need something to
kind of look like 3d but it doesn't
actually you don't like move around it
and in 30 world or something it's just
needs to kind of look 3d and official
you can use After Effects for that as
well okay after the place that's great
3d capabilities but you know 3d studio
max is again what you should be using
blender is a free alternative three to
do max costs like three and a half
thousand dollars I've still got my
student licenses going for it since
school so I'm still good for that but I
know that all over that's three tune of
Max's expense it was like three and a
half four four thousand dollars only so
it's it's really expensive but some
blenders free I can blend is really good
as well I've never actually committed to
using blender properly I fell asleep
metal drowned a bit like five years ago
or something but um
blenders blend is really good as well so
if you you know if you need start
somewhere if you would have done the
stuff before then you probably don't
have you probably two days to learn
blender if you want to do something 3d
for love there but blenders free again
there's also cinema 4d okay that is also
a pretty cool application it cost money
not as good as 3d studio max in my
experience and my experience in the
professional industry but certainly
viable is cheaper as well so that's
something to consider as well okay so
sound sound audacity okay audacity is
actually what I'm using to record this
this commentary so audacity is really
good it's free and it pretty much does
the job down done if you've got a
microphone you want to record some birds
you want to record a nice loud claps or
if that's get you you want to do someone
to that sound effects sound Foley you
can record that kind of stuff and add
effects to it certainly then audacity is
where it's at okay now it's free which
has that going for it the next one is
adobe audition I used to I used to use
that all the time for recording
commentaries as well because part of it
it'll be greatest wait yeah audition is
really good but I can't really make a
case for it because in the end at the
end of the day I use it for the same
thing as audacity so to me it's just
opacity with a different interface
obviously costing money so I can't
really say auditions good if you don't
if you don't want to you know audacity I
mean it's pretty hard not to know and
ouside used the record button at the top
of records but audacity and audition are
pretty much the same so yeah I know
addition probably has more features I
just don't use them so con doc well them
sony sound force Pro again auditions
only have 400 dasa t same [ __ ] different
day it's pretty much the exact same
software foregin sound for an audition
cost money order Hadees room so yeah I
said s well SFX I can barely pronounce
that s f XR and B FX are they are
they're really nice um audio editing
kind of you will sound generating
utilities is what I should call them
essentially their little the little
things written in flash that do sounds
and you can move these sliders around
and essentially the idea the idea with
them as you can use sign and different
like soul patterns and everything to
generate it sounds so in other words
picture like you're playing this as
Super Mario Brothers and you kind of
jump up and you collect a coin you hear
that sound that's kind of what those two
it that those two utilities will
generate so you can play around with
those two certainly and they will laugh
as far as sound effects that's pretty
much what I use okay for Genesis that
game that I made for Adam there 24 I
used and for bottom there 26 is squared
game that I made I used SF XR to
generate the sound effects okay so sound
effects honestly if you don't want to
record them yourselves
check out SFX R&B FX are okay you can
Google search them and they'll come up
they're very important they're very good
music now I don't know how much you can
talk about music because I know there's
a lot of you guys are probably game
developers and not musicians
I myself happen to be a musician as well
as a filmmaker and a game developer so
that kind of convenient I guess I
happened to be a musician I've been
playing piano like 14 years about 15
years now and guitar for like seven so
um so I know my way around music and
I've been writing music professionally
as well so there's that so naj okay I
want to start with something that you
guys could probably use if you knew just
not musicians because I know that it's
obvious
how to write music if you're not a
musician but not a notch up now go to
iodge dotnet play around that thing it's
basically a little it's basically a
little um little utility that has like a
matrix of sixteen by sixteen squares you
can actually add more time to it so the
first loop will be you'll see what I
mean when you go to the side but the
first loop is like four seconds or
something you probably you can actually
make it longer if you so please but
essentially you click on squares and you
are you make music okay and there are
different instruments and everything
it's really great if you're not a
musician but you want to add music to
your game that you make yourself which
you have to since it is love them there
and you have to make everything from
scratch Nadja's where it's at okay
seriously go check that out well if
you've liked if you're kind of scared
when it comes to them to the music part
of your game check that out it's really
great actually played around with it
about ten minutes before recording this
and it's just it's fantastic so
seriously go check me out and there's I
don't think that's a way to download it
I didn't find a way to download the
result your result of music but you
could use something like audacity to
just record it so you play it and then
you record it using audacity or B record
what your computers playing and then you
can use it in game okay
so that's fine so again if you're not
you know if you're not yes if you're not
a musician if you don't have a lot of
experience with music and you can't
really play any instruments or you just
don't have the recording setups to
record yourself playing then nagy is
really really good that'll let you write
music from scratch essentially I know
I've done that and it's free of course
so Apple Logic Pro is what I use Apple
Logic Pro or just Logic Pro Logic Pro 9
is about $1200 Logic Pro 10 all Logic
Pro X came out I think half a year ago
it's $200
I bought it it's amazing it's on the App
Store if you've got a Mac get it if
you're all seriously serious about music
I guess if you'd not just don't just
drop $200 for no reason because Turner
said so but um it's uh it's really good
ok quick note about that I know a lot of
people might be hesitant about buying
that because Final Cut 7 which is
Apple's video editing kind of software
suite Final Cut studio like 7 or Final
Cut 7 essentially was was really good
really really good I use that I actually
use that for a lot of time for a lot of
a lot of my professional life and then
if I have caught 10 it was complete
garbage now not sorry okay Apple Logic
Pro 10 has everything that 9 has plus
more and the interface is just a lot
better now so in other words the Logic
Pro is really good okay and that's what
I use to essentially record myself
playing a MIDI keyboard record myself
freaking playing guitar playing bass
guitar piano Inge singing whatever okay
Logic Pro is where it's at alternatives
Ableton Live I use that a lot before I
use Logic Pro Ableton Live is really
really good as well
I personally prefer a lot of pro I think
the inbuilt instruments I guess the
instruments that you can tie manually
you biologic Pro $400 and you get an
optional 36 gigabyte 36 gigabytes of
instruments that you can download for
free of course so um the library that
comes with Logic Pro is just a lot
better than the library that comes with
life so that's why I love probe of life
but Ableton Live is certainly very very
good as well okay if you know if you
know Ableton Live and you're like Walter
no it's recommending Logic Pro I don't
even have a Mac I'm just going to go out
and buy a Mac Pro and then I'm going to
learn Logic Pro and then it's gonna
freaking be two days away but I'm gonna
make sure I do that stuff before I'm
dead don't okay Appleton Live is
perfectly viable as well as is reason
okay I think it's [ __ ] I forgot the
company who made reason I should really
look this up right now it's up right now
come on it's propeller heads so
propeller heads made Razin Razin is
really good I used to use resin a lot if
you're used to working in a studio and
you're used to dealing with hardware
rather than software which potentially
could be you at yes if you work in a
recording studio or I don't know it's
somewhere that has a lot of sound
devices and you're dealing with hardware
and hot stuff like Hardware mixers
Hardware effects and Hardware processes
audio process and all that stuff reason
is for you because you can actually I
guess you can actually use patch cables
to connect stuff together it's really
really cool so reason is really good for
that as well Pro Tools is more of a
recording I think anyway last time I
checked it out probably like five years
ago it was more recording than a
creation kind of things done otherwise
you don't have MIDI I well you would now
but
my ProTools is also a really good one
it's the only one out of those that I
haven't used though so that's why I put
it last but I know it's really good so
anyway that's pretty much it guys that's
the software that I use that software
you should use follow me on Twitter
twitter.com force after Cherno and
Twitter TV for slash the channels where
I'm gonna be live-streaming myself doing
love them there 28 over the next wealth
it's gonna last for 48 hours but that
stream of course will start in two days
when a little of them dared I was like
yeah so um I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of what's not only an episode
but I hope you guys enjoyed this load
I'm there tip and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye